this is under the heading forward for
simultaneous equations simultaneously
now don't fret out these too much I want
you to actually forget a lot about what
you were thinking about if you've met
these before and I just want you to
treat this as a fresh idea and this will
take us to the valley okay nobody for
anything I just want you to follow with
me so in fact probably turns out of
hands is probably best I should help me
think through if you looked okay we're
printing a book that's what we're doing
printable the production costs of
printing your book are and then they
give you all of these conditions help
you wait this out initially eight
thousand dollars right so before you
have printed any books a thousand
dollars gets charged maybe to rent the
factory or debate like this entities
whatever it is eight thousand dollars
it's where you can do and then they
charge you more and more and more the
more [ __ ] print that makes sense this
is just like the situations we've been
looking before any linear model so help
me out if i print zero books how much
are they going to charge me initially
sorry initially it does not before you
actually make any books so i'm going to
go 8,000 right there where they had my
first thousand books how much does that
cost so it's the eight thousand plus the
first three so 11,000 what's next the
next thousand 1417 you get the idea okay
good 20 right ok now we're going to take
this and we're going to graph it on top
of this line it's already there that
before we do that I want you to have a
look at what don't mind me interpret it
with you right this is for the same
production of books how much income is
generated for how many books are sold
yourself zero book to make no money
every time you sell an extra book you
make a little bit more does that make
sense now what will happens when we put
these together okay eight thousand
dollars the initial value that's the
vertical intercept yeah
so where's 8,000 dogs look carefully in
my scale yeah this is thousands of
dollars right sir hey looks like it's
going to be yeah I can put a few more
points on to this I'm just going to go
straight to the end okay four thousand
books which is over here is going to
cost how much 20,000 sir if I go up
that's going to be here does that look
okay might be off by one or two squares
but I think that's pretty good ok now if
I putting in all the rest of the points
I can join this up in fact that's
exactly what I'm gonna do and I'm gonna
get this straight line B mag- please
well it's supposed to be magnetic but
are they okay now look carefully all
we've got here you got two straight
lines but that's interacting with each
other right I want you to imagine what
would happen if just hypothetical you
may you actually printed doughboyz right
and therefore you're not going to sell
any boss how much money have you lost
you've lost eight thousand dollars right
the bluegrass above the red one okay
let's think about it if I go up to here
a thousand bucks right you're going to
spend a bit more but you can sell them
so you can make some money right now
without knowing what the number is how
do I work out how much money I've lost
cuz stall us money where is it on this
ground it's the gap very good you can
see where's my other color no this will
do you can see that eight thousand
dollars you told me before it was this
distance right there okay if I be over
21 this distance it gets smaller right
I'm sorry to make back some of my money
okay what's this point right here the
graphs overlap bring the point where you
start earning okay so this means right
the exact amount of money i said to make
the books is the exact amount of money
I've earned by selling them okay this is
what we call the break-even point okay
break-even point it's actually a really
important
turn right after you post that assuming
you can sell everything right look at
what happens the cost of production is
now less than how much I can actually
earn by selling these things right so
what's happening I've got a profit out
ray right and the more you get suppose
you can actually sell them the more you
can actually learn okay as in dennys